PROGRAM, HE WAS OFFERED THE JOB
AND HE REGRETTED TURNING IT
DOWN.
SHE DIDN'T PAY ATTENTION.
AND WE'LL HAVE SEBAEFTIAN GORKAN
AND SECRET SERVICE AGENT DAN.
STARTING WITH YOU.
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT THE MAYOR
SAID LAST NIGHT.
AND THE PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY
SAID LAST NIGHT ABOUT HILLARY
AND ABOUT MUELLER AND ABOUT
COMEY AND THE INVESTIGATION,
HUGE NEWS THAT HE'S MAKING HERE,
AND THEY FOCUS ON 30 SECONDS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE CORRUPT
MEDIA GOES.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HEAR THE
TRUTH.
>> FIRST THINGS FIRST.
I HAVE TO CONGRATULATE YOU, YOU
ARE GETTING CLOSE TO THE
PRESIDENT'S RECORD FOR LIVING
RENT FREE IN THE MIND OF THE
LIBERAL LEFT WING MEDIA.
THEY ARE OBSESSED WITH YOU.
AND I LIKE HOW THEY SFENT THE
WHOLE DAY.
THEY SELECTED ONE-HALF OF
A SENTENCE FROM THE MAYOR'S
STATEMENT AND THEY MISSED THE
BEGINNING.
AMONGST OTHER THINGS THAT'S THE
REASON WHY HE WAS FIRED.
AND THESE PEOPLE INVENTORY
PASSED YEAR ONE IN JOURNALISM
SCHOOL AND THEY HAVE TO MAINTAIN
A NARRATIVE.
LIKE THE 49 QUESTIONS.
THEY ARE A MARK OF DESPERATION.
THERE IS NO CASE.
THERE IS NO CONCLUSION AND
THREE- QUARTERS OF THE QUESTION
IS TRYING TO POLICE YOUR
THOUGHT.
WE ONLY DO THAT IN DICTATORSHIP
AND NOT IN AMERICA, SEAN.
>> Sean: WHAT DID YOU THINK OF
COMB'S'S TELL.
AND WHAT DID YOU THINK OF
SESSION'S REUSUAL.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT HE
THOUGHT.
IT MATTERS WHAT HE DID.
>> NO.
>> Sean: AND THE FACT THAT THAT
GOES OVER HIS HAND ONE HAND
INFURIATES ME AND THEN ON THE
OTHER HAND I HAVE TO LAUGH.
RUDY GUILIANI TALKS ABOUT HOW
MUELLER'S QUESTIONSAR A PERJURY
TRAP AND COMEY IS A DISGRACEFUL
LIAR AND HOW HILLARY IS
A CRIMINAL AND BELONGS IN JAIL
AND COMEY FIXED THE ENTIRE CASE
WITH HILLARY AND TALKED ABOUT
HOW COMEY SHOULD BE PROSECUTED
FOR LEAKING CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION.
NONE MUCH THAT IS COVERED TODAY.
BUT THE ONLY THING THEY COVER IS
STORMY, STORMY AND EVEN GOT THAT
WRONG.
>> WELL, SEAN, THEY ARE INVESTED
IN IT NOW.
THEY CAN'T GET AWAY FROM THE
RUSSIA HOAX.
AND SOLD IT FOR A YEAR.
THIS IS A CASE BUILT BY LIAR
ACCIDENT.
CLAPPER AND BRENNAN AND COMEY.
THEY BUILT IT ON A BED OF LIES
FOR LIARS ON CAPITAL AND PEOPLE
IN THE MEDIA WHO OBTRUKTED THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
LET ME TELL YOU, WHEN I WAS
A SECRET SERVICE AGENCY.
I WENT TO AN ADVANCED
INTERROGATION SCHOOL.
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY TAUGHT